* Rasante Rockmusik *
# I can't surf.
* Unverständliche Funkdurchsage *
Guten Morgen zusammen!
- Guten Morgen, Steffi!
Guten Morgen, Steffi!
* Rasante Rockmusik *
Heutzutage ist es ...
Ja, es ist halt in der Gesellschaft
verankert, dass ...
Uns geht es halt allen sehr gut.
Und die Leute
wollen halt konsumieren -
masslos, aus meiner Sicht.
Aber das
lässt sich fast nicht ändern.
Für mich ist das ja
an und für sich etwas Gutes.
Das gibt uns immer genug Arbeit.
Das ist unser Schlepperfahrer,
der alles einlädt.
Das hier sind unsere Rollboxen.
Sie werden mit Paketen gefüllt.
Die Ortschaft
ist oben angeschrieben.
Ich habe vor 14 Jahren
hier angefangen.
Man merkt es schon:
Jedes Jahr wird es mehr.
V.a. wollen die Leute,
ich inklusive,
ihre Pakete noch schneller haben.
Deswegen haben wir es
im Tagesdienst ruhiger,
aber im Nachtdienst,
wenn es priorisiert werden muss,
nimmt es hauptsächlich
immer mehr zu.
Dann haben wir manchmal vielleicht
Schwierigkeiten, alles einzuhalten.
Die Pakete kommen in Lastwagen,
Zügen oder wie auch immer zu uns.
Die Kranführerin entlädt sie.
Sie stellt den Behälter
auf solche Abstellfüsse.
Unter diese
fährt der Platzfahrzeugfahrer,
hebt den Behälter an
und bringt ihn zu den Toren.
Hier sind die Koordinaten, damit ich
weiss, wohin ich fahren muss.
Ich bin Tanja Eggimann.
Ich bin hier seit zehn Jahren
Kranführerin.
Hier in Härkingen.
Ich bin dafür zuständig,
die Wechselbehälter
von A nach B zu stellen.
Das sind meine Sicherheitslampen.
So weiss ich,
dass hier alle vier Kontakt haben.
Mir gefällt das Kranfahren ...
... und dass ich hier oben
klare Anweisungen habe
und für mich alleine bin.
Konsum ist gut,
wenn die Leute bestellen.
D.h., dass ich Arbeit habe.
(Funk) Kannst du das bitte
noch schnell machen?
Jawohl.
Ich bin Fanta Thomas.
Ich fahre hier auf der Hoflogistik
als Platzfahrzeugfahrer.
Ich bringe eigentlich Container
von A nach B.
Z.B. diesen hier.
Ich fahre mal darunter.
Es ist mein Traumjob.
Ich bin schön für mich alleine.
Ich habe einfach meine Ruhe.
Ich kann den ganzen Tag Musik hören.
Das ist für mich sehr, sehr wichtig.
Und ich steuere selbstverständlich
sehr gerne grosse Fahrzeuge.
Platzfahrzeugfahrer bekommen
Aufträge von unserer Leitstelle.
Da heisst es: "Container Nummer 9022
muss zum Tor 220."
Der Platzfahrzeugfahrer fährt
unten rein, hebt den Container an,
bringt ihn zu Tor 220
und lädt ihn wieder ab.
Dann kommt der nächste Auftrag.
Ich bestelle sicher auch etwas.
Aber ich versuche,
es auf einem Minimum zu halten.
Zwei-, dreimal im Jahr vielleicht.
Wenn es möglich ist,
kaufe ich es auch noch selber ein,
aber das
ist halt auch nicht immer möglich.
Grundsätzlich ist es ja etwas Gutes,
wenn man die Möglichkeit hat,
fast alles zu bekommen.
An der Umsetzung, wie es ist ...
Wenn man jetzt
z.B. diverse Kleider bestellt ...
... und nachher
von den zehn Paketen mit Kleidern
neun wieder zurückschickt,
ist das alles andere als nachhaltig.
Davon bin ich kein so grosser Fan.
Die Zeit schreitet voran.
Alles wird moderner.
Geschäfte werden verschwinden.
Das lässt sich nicht vermeiden.
Das ist so wie früher, als
die Postkutschen im Wilden Westen
eigentlich vom Zug verdrängt wurden.
Das blüht halt auch den Geschäften.
Das blüht mir - als Chauffeur.
Früher oder später
werde ich wohl durch
ein autonomes Fahrzeug ersetzt.
Ja, das lässt sich nicht aufhalten.
Das ist halt die Zukunft.
Es geht immer vorwärts.
* Rasante Rockmusik *
# I can't surf.
Ich heisse Petra D'Angelo.
Ich arbeite seit 17 Jahren
als Codiererin
hier im Paketzentrum in Härkingen.
Ich erfasse Adressen, welche
die Anlage selber nicht lesen kann.
Ich denke, ich scanne
etwa 5'000 Pakete pro Tag.
Wenn ich ehrlich bin:
Manchmal bestellen wir Sachen -
ich inklusive -,
die man nicht unbedingt braucht.
Man sieht es, denkt:
"Oh, das ist noch lustig!",
und bestellt es.
Mir ergeht es nicht anders.
Ich denke,
wenn jeder darauf achten würde,
würde man vielleicht
ein bisschen weniger bestellen.
Aber das wäre ja nicht gut,
dann hätten wir weniger Arbeit.
Die grossen hier,
die zweitgrössten da
und die kleinen dort.
Dann werden sie
genau auf diese Weise sortiert.
Jemand sonst
legt sie vielleicht anders hin,
aber ich mache es so.
Es muss einfach
super anständig sein.
Die ganz schweren Pakete
haben wir unten.
Die mittleren und kleinen,
also nicht schweren, haben wir oben.
Dann müssen wir schauen:
Manchmal wird die Schachtel
schlecht zugeklebt.
Wenn das unten zusammendrückt,
fällt der ganze Stapel um.
Deswegen habe ich dieses
rübergeschoben.
Ich bin Johann Ulrich Anderegg.
Am 1. November
habe ich hier meinen letzten Tag.
Am 3. November werde ich 65.
Jetzt bin ich am Morgen meistens
hier bei Zalando eingeteilt.
Ich mache einfach
die Retoursendungen.
Das sind alles Waren,
die zurückgeschickt werden.
Sie kommen aus dem gesamten Gebiet:
aus der Innerschweiz
oder aus dem Tessin.
Bei Zalando
gibt es extrem viele Rücksendungen.
Ich selber habe keinen Computer.
Ich bestelle nicht.
Wenn ich das sagen darf:
Ich gehe lieber in die Geschäfte.
Ich mag Loeb.
Wir hatten auch noch Schild.
Heute ist das ja wieder anders.
Ich gehe lieber in die Geschäfte.
Der eine macht es so,
der andere anders.
Das ist jedem seine Sache.
* Rockmusik *